okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others uh it's always fun
for me
please ask whatever kinds of uh
uh obvious unobvious questions
about anything around science technology
history future etc all right we have a
few
questions that have been saved up from
last week
um the question from eggy here can you
explain computational irreducibility
like you're telling a six-year-old
hmm okay
let's see six-year-old
i always have the point of view that i
don't deal with children under the age
of
10. but um we'll we'll see what we can
do here
all right
i think um
let's uh let's talk about
um what computers do
so you have a computer you have
something like
a um a cell phone it's running a program
it's doing something what's it going to
do how are you going to tell what it's
going to do
can you figure how do you figure out
what your computer is going to do
well you might say
how does a computer work inside a
computer
has a program that tells it what to do
it tells it every step of what to do the
question is what's it going to do
when it's run many steps i think the um
the thing uh we're kind of
um uh well let me let me maybe explain
computational irreducibility
uh for anybody and then maybe we can um
uh
see what concepts we need to have that
are or not available to a modern
six-year-old
talking about computers and what
computers and phones do is something
that
is only possible in modern times with
with uh
uh with your average six-year-old so to
speak
but um uh so
you know here's really the question if
you have
a computer or something else that's set
up to follow rules
let's say you were following rules that
told you how to color squares on a piece
of paper
you have particular rules you keep
following these rules you keep
coloring the squares you keep on doing
it you keep on doing it you do it 10
times you do it a million times
the big question is can you figure out
what these colored squares going to look
like after you've done
followed that rule a million times can
you figure that out
by some in some way that's quicker than
just
following the rule a million times
that's really the question can you kind
of
be smarter jump ahead figure out what
it's what it's going to do
before it does it itself and like with a
computer
can you figure out if if you sort of
took the computer apart
looked at what's going on inside could
you understand what it's doing to the
point where you could say
oh this is what's going to do in the end
i don't have to actually run the
computer
to see what happens i think that um
uh the the the sort of the big
idea of computational irreducibility is
how easy is it to predict what's going
to happen with something
how even if you know what the steps it's
taking are
how easy is it to kind of jump ahead and
say this is what the consequence
of running a thousand a million whatever
steps is going to be
now why does that um
let's imagine that you have uh something
that is i don't know let's say it was a
it was a a plant or a tree
and um let's say that it grows in little
steps
and every step it just follows some rule
that says how to grow based on what it's
grown so far
question is can you tell what shape that
plant will be
just from knowing what that rule is or
do you have to let the rule run
and and see what the plant what what
shape the plant ends up being
boy i'm doing really poorly here on on
the i think as i say
my theory if i i i can't deal with kids
under the age of 10
seems to be uh seems to be playing out
here it's it's very interesting to see
what concepts
one needs to have in order to explain an
idea like computational irreducibility
i mean i think that the the thing that
in a sense
is is familiar to
somewhat older people is this idea that
there is some way one can figure out
what's going to happen there's some way
one can use math
one can use science one can use
something else to figure out
this is what is going to happen in some
system that we're looking at
and people have gotten used to the idea
that
oh with science we can predict what's
going to happen we can predict
this or that feature of the weather we
can predict this or that feature of some
mechanical system
something like that we can um we can
use science to predict things the the
sort of the big surprise of
computational irreducibility
is that from within science itself one's
being told
that there are limitations on what
predictions can be made
and essentially the the point is what
does it mean to make a prediction
it means that you're going to be able to
kind of
be more computationally sophisticated
than the system you're predicting
the system itself is going to go through
all these steps do all these things
follow all these rules
all these times but you're going to say
oh no
you know you didn't need to follow those
million steps i can
just use a better smarter procedure
and work out what's going to happen in a
sense that's sort of the triumph
of existing you know the mathematical
sciences and so on
the big triumph has been to find all
those ways to sort of jump ahead and
predict what's going to happen
without having to follow all the steps
what computational irreducibility is
telling one
is that actually there are many systems
many situations in which you can't do
that kind of jumping ahead
and figuring out what's going to happen
i mean there's a there's a lot of kind
of significance to this idea of
computational irreducibility
in terms of the way that we think about
sort of the
the limits of science that is we might
say
oh you know in the end we'll be able to
figure out everything about how the
world works
um and uh what computational
irreducibility is telling us is no we
won't
and what's interesting is the the sort
of the origin of computational
irreducibility
is this is this competition that exists
in doing science between
the system you're observing and the
observer
observing it and making predictions
about it and sort of the origin of
computational irreducibility
is this thing that i call the principle
of computational equivalence
which basically says that if you look at
sort of how sophisticated the
computation that gets done
by different systems is there's
equivalence between these so
there's the computations that are
getting done by some system that is made
out of little physical components
or it's made by simple rules that one
can describe in terms of black and white
squares or something
uh as that the the sophistication of the
computation that's getting down in that
system
is just the same as the sophistication
of the computation that's getting done
by any other kind of system we can make
in our universe including our brains
our elaborate mathematics those kinds of
things
and so it's the fact that these things
are equivalent that means that when we
look at that system that we think oh
it's got these very simple rules we
should be able to predict what it's
going to do
well actually no because it's doing a
computation just as sophisticated as the
ones
that go on in our brains and so we can't
expect the one that's going on in our
brains
to be able to kind of shortcut outrun
the computation that's being done by the
system
that we can readily see has simple
underlying rules simple underlying
components
so what's the significance of that what
does that mean
well it means that there may be things
where we have succeeded
at a sort of level of reductionism in
science we we've succeeded in finding
what are the underlying components of
the system we know how the
what the components are but nevertheless
when you put those components together
and you ask what will the overall
behavior of the system be you may not be
answered able to answer that question
except by essentially running the system
and seeing what it does
so so in a sense that what that's saying
is that
even though we are successful in the
science of reducing it to say what the
components are
we still haven't managed to sort of uh
pull the whole system in
and just say science has crushed this
system
and we can immediately say what it will
do it has a lot of
a lot of implications for a lot of kinds
of of things where
people say look surely science can
predict
you know what's going to happen to the
earth of you know 300 years from now
you can predict what's going to happen
with uh this or that
you know the thing about pandemics this
or that
you know medical thing that you observe
you know is this going to grow is this
not going to grow
these these kinds of things is this uh
kind of um
thing that we set up in some kind of you
know uh
social system going to do this or that
thing is this kind of economic thing
going to work in this or that way
there's this question of can science
just say
okay you've set up these rules for this
economic system now i know what's going
to happen
well what computational irreducibility
says is
yes you may know the rules but that
doesn't mean you can make a large scale
statement about what will happen
it may be that the only way you can know
what's going to happen is just to follow
through each step and see what happens
now you might say that's really that's
really disappointing you know
that science can't go further in some
sense it is but in some sense
it's also telling us a different thing
because
in a sense if we imagine sort of leading
our lives
doing what we do and so on and we say
look you know all this effort you're
putting into leading your life and doing
what you do
it's all kind of a waste of time because
we can use science to jump ahead
and say the answer is going to be 42 or
something
and what computational irreducibility
says is
no there's actually something sort of
achieved by this sort of
inexorable process that is the the
the progression of time and the things
that happen in sort of the
the progress of our lives so to speak so
in a sense computational irreducibility
is saying
there is something meaningful achieved
by the passage of time
it isn't just something where you can
say oh we can just jump to the end
and you know look at the end of the book
and see what happened so
so that's kind of the so computational
disability
is both the good news of there's
something meaningful about the
progression of time
and the bad news that you can't jump
ahead in time so to speak
and see what's going to happen uh
without sort of putting in the effort to
go through all those individual steps
and so that there are when we start
applying this
this to thinking about what that means
for for how we set up systems in the
world and so on and how we think about
the role of science in the world
it's kind of interesting because it
really tells us
there are things that we can uh that
they're things where
we have been sort of conditioned over
the last particular century or so
to just say science is going to be able
to answer things we you know we've got
it
science has it we don't need uh you know
that that's that's going to give us all
the answers
but this is really saying computational
irreducibility is really the force
from within science that explains
that's just not going to work out that
way and as i say i
i view it as sort of good news in the
sense that it is
explaining that the progress of time
is meaningful it isn't something that is
just we're doing all the stuff but it's
sort of
a waste of time it's something where we
could just jump ahead and
and make use of that now you know the
question that was posed here was
explain computational irreducibility to
a six-year-old
and i think the place i would have to go
is to say
let's let's try writing down some little
rules
get a piece of graph paper just try
writing some things down
use a computer look at something like
a cellular automata for example see
here's a rule
here's what it does you can follow that
rule you can do it on a piece of graph
paper
look you can actually make it make it go
and you can see that the
following that rule makes the same
pattern that the computer says it makes
but now let's make the computer run it
and let's make the computer run it for
10 000 steps here's the elaborate
pattern it produces
can you figure out what this pattern is
going to look like after 10 000 steps
or not and can you imagine that it's
possible to figure out what it's going
to look like after 10 000 steps
you might say well you know there's a
there's a piece here that looks like
it's a big sort of lump of stuff that's
all the same and
so on but you know look at a bit more
detail can you predict
no you can't predict so the question is
is there is there any way to predict
this
and what you start thinking about is
well
let's try and imagine we make another
set of rules that are the predictor
rules for this set of rules
can we do that what might be in those
rules are we ever going to be able to do
that
now in a sense uh and i'm not sure
whether this is uh
six year old accessible but um in a
sense sort of part of the proof that
that's not possible
is the idea of programmable computers
the idea that
from within one computer you can make it
do
by setting up a different program you
can make it do whatever any other
computer can do
i'm not sure how easy that is to explain
i think that that's become
in sort of the course of of the
development of mathematics and science
that was an idea that came very late
that was an idea that didn't
really take hold until probably the
1940s or so
although they've been sort of precursors
of a little bit earlier and even there
were sort of thoughts about in the 1800s
with people like charles babba jada
lovelace
there were thoughts about it even
earlier from people like gottfried
leibniz in the 1600s
but the full idea really only emerged
sort of mathematically in the 1920s and
1930s
and sort of in the way that it was
applied in the 1940s and 1950s
um so it's sort of a very recent idea
but the notion that you can make a
computer
that you can have something which is
programmable you can have something
where
you know you have your phone and by just
pressing this button you can make
your phone be a camera you can make your
phone be something that's reading email
you can make your phone
be something that's playing a game and
so on the fact that you have this fixed
object
that you're able to just sort of press a
button and have it be like something
else
that's an idea that is now part of sort
of everyday consciousness
but that's that's kind of the idea of
programmability
and in a sense if you can say well this
thing that you just drew out
with these little rules you made
actually it's possible to make that
thing that you just drew out with these
rules
into something which in principle you
could run a game
on you could uh uh you know run run a
word processor on and so on
then then you start realizing that well
look if you can do that based on these
simple rules
how could it be the case that we could
sort of jump ahead and figure out what
these rules are going to do because
after all
these rules might be whatever it is that
we're trying to use to jump ahead
we might we can emulate the thing where
we're using to jump ahead in the rule
itself
and so you kind of get into this
circular argument where you start
realizing that that's not going to be
possible and that's kind of the
the standard diagonal argument that
leads to to results about
undecidability from um uh from touring
and godel on
all right that was um uh i wasn't very
satisfied with that i think i should be
able to do better there
um all right let's see
um
okay so question from pranjul
how different is nanotechnology
manufacturing
from normal manufacturing
well it's an interesting question not
least because nanotechnology
manufacturing hasn't really taken off
i mean there was a time maybe 20 25
years ago
when people were talking a lot about
molecular manufacturing
talking a lot about making things
uh where they were sort of pieces of
machinery that operate at the atomic
scale
um the uh that
the the idea tended to be let's
take things we know how to do at a large
scale
and let's shrink them down and operate
them at the scale of individual atoms or
molecules
um that turned out to be pretty hard to
do
it's in a sense the the examples that we
have of things sort of operating and
doing things at the scale of atoms and
molecules
those are really that's really the story
of chemistry is you know chemistry is
about you've got this molecule it's a
bunch of atoms
and this molecule can be in a certain
environment or can interact with other
molecules
it'll change its configuration it'll
it'll twist itself around it'll do this
thing or that thing
in a sense the what we've got when we
set up a molecule of a particular
structure
is we're making like a tiny machine a
molecule many molecules that operate
like tiny machines
that's particularly true in biomolecules
where
where we're typically using you know
these sequences of amino acids to make
proteins
these big molecules of millions of atoms
in them and so on that have particular
shapes and have particular
mechanical properties and electrical
properties and they
they they operate they do some
particular thing when when they get an
electric uh
you know if they're a muscle uh piece of
actin filament for
the protein that makes muscles you know
when they get uh
when they get some uh electrical um
stimulation they'll contract things like
this or when
if it's something where it's a um
it's a cell that um is part of some uh
you know kidney filtering system or
something it'll have some other property
that
it'll pass through it'll it'll uh you
know secrete
potassium or something if it sodium
whatever
if it if it um if it is in this
environment et cetera et cetera et
cetera these are all like
little uh the the you know the level of
individual molecules you can end up with
with sort of little micro machines that
do things and that's been kind of the
in a sense the an objective of chemistry
is to try and do something like that but
they're not
the machines we build in chemistry are
not nearly as elaborate
as the kind of machines that we expect
to build uh with large-scale
manufacturing
so i think that the um uh in in typical
manufacturing
what you're doing is you're saying
here's my
uh here's my construction plan
i'm just going to put these pieces
together i'm going to stamp something
out
with a you know i'm going to put
something make something from a mold
things like this what you tend to think
of in chemistry
is something more like a kind of a
more kind of self-assembly where you've
got these individual pieces of molecules
or atoms
and somehow they're assembling
themselves in such a way as to make the
thing you want i mean this happens for
example with virus capsids the
the coatings of viruses they they
they're often like for example
icosahedral shapes
and the way that works is there are
particular proteins that are particular
shapes
and when you just have these proteins
kind of knocking around
they'll tend to form themselves into
these into these
uh kind of elaborate looking icosahedral
shapes and so
kind of the the idea that the the hope i
think
in well a couple of different approaches
but but at least
my feeling is the most likely way to be
able to
to create kind of molecular scale
machinery is by
this kind of process that's a little bit
like chemistry where you've got this
long series of steps where
each step you're arranging that this
thing is
is being done sort of globally to to a
whole collection of molecules that
causes the molecules to add this little
piece
that does this does this does this and
eventually you have a molecule
that is exactly the shape you want now
another approach
that's never been successfully done is
to have something where you can
essentially
knit a molecule together uh by
by doing something where you almost have
or do something like 3d printing
where you almost have a print head
that's printing individual atoms
i mean we can do this to some extent
with atomic force microscopes
we can kind of place atoms in individual
places but it's not really something
where we can make something that is a
we don't we don't really have it's not
practical to make something which has
sort of a large-scale
uh structure at a molecular scale
and um so you know one of the
possibilities is that maybe there's a
way maybe there's a trick
that allows one to make sort of a print
head at a molecular scale
that can just place an atom wherever you
want i mean i've always wondered
you know for example if you take carbon
which can
make which can be formed into a variety
of different structures whether
it's graphite or diamond or buckyballs
or whatever else you take um
could you make something which would
just form an arbitrary molecular
structure
with putting carbon atoms in different
places
and uh could you sort of build a printer
that would do that and you kind of
imagine
sort of an interesting chain of things
happening you know first you build the
big printer which builds something a
little bit smaller
then that builds a printer that builds
something even smaller
you keep going until eventually you have
this thing
that is kind of the the molecular scale
printer so to speak
that itself can then print more
molecular scale printers
so that's kind of the the notion of how
that might work although
although i think the the kind of um
uh the enthusiasm for for doing this and
and figuring out how to make it work has
kind of waned in the last 25 years or so
i think eventually this will be possible
eventually it will be possible
to uh to build sort of machinery at the
molecular scale but
we're not really there yet
okay there's a question here um
about what is the historical
relationship between chemistry and
physics
is chemistry a sub-branch of physics
well you know at different times in
history
kind of physics has been the top science
or chemistry has been sort of the top
science
i think that um let's talk about the
relationship between physics and
chemistry
uh famous physicist from around 100
years ago ernest rutherford
uh had a rather unkind thing to say
about chemistry he described
science as being broken into these two
large domains
one was physics and the other he said
was stamp collecting
and by stamp collecting he was referring
to chemistry
why did he say that the reason he said
that was
that to him it seemed that physics was
very organized
physics had very had a set of principles
it had a set of physical laws
from which you could work out all these
things once you knew
the laws of mechanics the laws of
electrodynamics
there were all these things you could
figure out about the physical world
but chemistry at least in those days
didn't seem like that at all
chemistry seemed like there were just
this whole collection
of random facts you know the boiling
point of this is that
the melting point of this is that this
chemical reaction happens
that chemical reaction happens and so on
it seemed like a collection of very
arbitrary facts
compared to physics so how has that
evolved and how does one understand that
well i think the first thing that one
can ask is when one is looking at the
properties of molecules and things
to what extent can one use those
physical laws to deduce how these
molecules should work
well the answer is that in principle we
know how to do it
the the molecules exist at a small scale
they're governed by quantum mechanics
they're governed by primarily by
something called schrodinger's equation
which is a
differential equation that basically
says
these are the probability amplitudes for
different
for electrons to be at different places
in molecules et cetera et cetera et
cetera
okay you can just write down those
equations for a certain kind of molecule
you can say okay
here are the equations there's you know
500 equations
just okay computer go and solve these
equations
well excuse me
well the problem is
that uh it's hard to solve those
equations
in fact there's some trickiness to do
with it
specifically with the way that electrons
work that make those equations
particularly hard to solve
um and uh it's but but basically
we know the equations it's really just a
question of grinding and crunching them
hard enough to be able to solve them and
figure out
what should this molecule be like and so
on
the state of the art today is that if
you have a molecule with about 100 atoms
you can do a pretty decent job figuring
out
what the structure of that molecule made
from from that collection of 100 atoms
will be
if i throw you 10 000 atoms you can't do
a perfect job using quantum mechanics
you can make an approximation you can
make a pretty decent approximation
by just imagining that there are these
sort of uh uh
just sort of classical mechanics like
force laws
you know with atoms being attracted to
other atoms or repelling other atoms
and so you get a decent approximation to
that by the time you have big big long
floppy molecules like proteins
it becomes even harder and even that
method
isn't particularly successful at
predicting the shape of a protein
molecule
so it's a um so
the physics gives you the underlying
laws working out
what consequences that has to the
structure of molecules is pretty hard
and and can really only be done for
small molecules now if you say what
about chemical reactions what is a
chemical reaction
something like you know uh hydrochloric
acid interacts with sodium chloride to
to do this or that um you know what what
actually happens in a chemical reaction
what happens in a chemical reaction is
that these molecules
are floating around it might be it might
be
molecules in a gas it might be molecules
in a liquid the molecules are moving
around
and every so often these two molecules
get close enough together
that the forces between the electrons in
them
are significant uh when the molecules
are far apart they kind of don't notice
each other but when the molecules get
really close together
there are uh there are there are things
where where for example the electrons
from one molecule can sort of be
be kind of the same places the electrons
from the other molecule
that they can be sort of they the
molecules kind of interpenetrate
and the question is what will happen and
the answer is that's
really hard to work out we know the
underlying physics of what's going on
but to actually work out what happens in
that chemical reaction
is really hard and it's it's really at
the at the
you know for tiny molecules people are
able to do it with very elaborate
computations these days
to do that for big molecules is really
undoable at this point
and and a lot of what has to happen is
uh it's really a question
of of uh of just doing a physical
experiment to find out what chemical
reaction happens
by the way i was talking earlier about
computational irreducibility
and this is very much an example of that
i think um
that even though we know the underlying
rules by which
these kind of chemical processes work
to actually figure out the consequences
of those rules
is kind of involves an irreducible
amount of computational work
okay so why does that relate to the
physics versus stamp collecting issue
the point is that because these things
are so hard to work out
it's as if the answers are just kind of
random
it's it's not like if if they were easy
to work out we'd expect oh yes they're
kind of
evenly spaced numbers and it's all very
straightforward but they're really hard
to work out there's a lot of sort of
computational depth there
and that that has the consequence that
when we just look at the result we say
what's the melting point of this thing
it's it's like it seems like a round
number
talking about melting points it's a good
example so
what what does it mean to to for
something to melt
well means it goes from being a solid to
being a liquid how do you take
if you have a particular kind of
molecule the question is
uh when something melts what's happening
is
you're putting temperature you're
putting heat into the material
and these molecules are just jiggling
around more and more they're jiggling
more and more
and eventually they jiggle so much that
they don't get
they don't adhere properly and they and
the whole thing becomes a liquid
but as you cool the thing down the
amount of heat the amount of jiggling
of these molecules goes down and
eventually the molecules kind of
lock together in a certain pattern like
a jigsaw puzzle or something
and they form a crystal and the question
is just
how much just how how much jostling is
allowed while not breaking that crystal
and that depends in detail on kind of
how the crystal is formed
and when you have very simple molecules
it can be quite straightforward to see
how the crystal how these molecules
would line themselves up
to make a crystal but when you have more
complicated molecules even that becomes
really hard
it's like imagine you're doing a jigsaw
puzzle maybe even with a bunch of
identical
identical pieces and ask the question
can you actually fill out
this whole plane of this jigsaw puzzle
you know we know
get these two pieces to fit together but
does that one fit oh if we did it this
way would we be able to fit
that one backwards and et cetera et
cetera et cetera can you
can you tile things based on this
particular set of tiles
it's actually known that that's a
computationally irreducible problem
it's known that the general question of
given a set of tiles
does there exist a tiling of the whole
plane that can be made with those tiles
that's an undecidable question
there's no limit on how much
computational effort it may take in a
sense
how far you may be able to tile a
thousand tiles ten thousand tiles
and then whoops there's no way to fit
the next tile in there's no
because there's some very complicated
pattern of tiles
that solves the problem of tiling the
whole plane
well if you're uh and by the way this is
the the simplest examples where it's
really hard to do this
involve oh two or three tiles depending
on what kinds of shapes they have
the kind of the most obvious thing would
be oh you're making a tiling
um let's just make a italian that's
periodic whether where the thing is just
identical copies identically arranged
it's just like a square grid or
something like this
we know that there are more complicated
cases for example with pairs of tiles
in the plane there are things like
penrose tiles where it's possible to
to cover the whole plane with tiles but
there's no way to do it periodically
there's no way so that you get it so
that
one piece of the tiling you just shift
it over you get
it's the same it's the same it's the
same instead those particular tilings
form these kind of nested structures
where no well you can never
it can never be the case that you just
sort of shift over and get the same
thing
in any case if you're just a poor
collection of molecules
trying to form yourselves into a crystal
the question is can you make a tiling
can you
can you solve that jigsaw puzzle problem
to make everything
line up and and make a crystal and the
point is that
when the shape of the molecule is
complicated that can be a really hard
problem
and so what that means is when when when
when nature
answers that question it's sort of doing
a sophisticated computation
and so the answer that winds up being oh
the melting point of this
is blah ends up being something that is
sort of the output of a big computation
and so if you just look at those numbers
they'll just look like random numbers
and that's kind of why uh sort of
chemistry tends to have this feel
of being sort of more random than
physics so to speak because
it's a it's a sort of a depth of
computation above
what one is typically looking at in
physics now it's worth explaining
something about
what physics is versus what chemistry is
and so on
you know what is physics is it the study
of all possible physical systems well no
not really
the physics that you'll find in a
physics textbook is
places where the methods that physics
has used
get you answers it's like oh what
happens if you have
a uh you know if you have an object
that's
um uh that's uh sort of projected
through
a vacuum and uh goes in this way with
this gravitational field and things like
this
it's it's situations where methods
typically mathematical methods
of of standard physics tell you the
answer to the question
there are plenty of physical systems
where it's actually really hard to get
an answer like for example
if you look at a fluid which is flowing
like water or something flows quickly
it'll make all this random turbulence
figuring out how that random turbulence
works is really hard
you don't find it in most physics
textbooks because the methods of physics
don't really tell you very much about
fluid turbulence
same thing is true if you look at i
don't know the motion of uh
earth moon sun system that's pretty
complicated
won't be discussed in most physics books
the three-body problem
because it's a really it's really
complicated and the methods of physics
don't
allow you to make general statements
about it
so in a sense physics has constrained
itself to be talking about
things about which its methods can
can give you successful results and it
all looks good because when we build
engineering on top of physics
we're making use of those parts of
physics that
where we can make statements and so it
looks like well we're doing all the
physics we need to do
because it's all the physics we need to
support the engineering we're doing but
in a sense that's because the
engineering we're doing
is based on the physics that we know how
to do now in chemistry
it's a little bit the same thing that
there are certain kinds of
chemical reactions that we understand
their effects even if we don't
understand
the microscopic level of detail what's
going on at the level of individual
atoms and so on but we know the effects
and so on
and so in chemistry similarly we're kind
of building up this
tower of things which we sort of can
understand using the methods of
chemistry
and i think one of the things that's
sort of exciting as we think about
things more computationally
is both physics and chemistry they're
kind of converging
because as we look at things where the
behavior is more complex in physics
the kinds of questions we run into are
very similar to the questions we run
into when we're looking at
things that sort of but we ask more
complex questions in chemistry
and both of them are converging to
basically be a story about computation
and whether it's whether we're looking
in chemistry at the construction of some
molecule that has some
complicated property and what's involved
in doing that construction
whether we're looking in physics what
does the uh how does how do things work
with um with some system that has more
complicated behavior and so on they're
sort of converging in some sense
and i think that um historically
i mean different uh you know chemistry
had a really big period in the late
1800s very early 1900s
actually physics was big at that time as
well but chemistry
the idea that you could make materials
you could make substances
that hadn't really existed in the world
uh plastic being one of the most
prominent examples
that was a thing that was sort of a a
phenomenon of the
of the real growth of chemistry in the
chemical industry in the late 1800s
to early 1900s i think that physics
has had different moments when it's
really when it's really shown
moments when you know fundamental
physics particle physics was really
doing very well
moments when the physics of condensed
matter of solids of solids and
and semiconductors and all this kind of
thing was doing really well
um i think that uh what we're seeing now
is is
kind of a convergence of the questions
that come up in those two fields
in fact we see even in some of the more
formal things about um
our physics project looking at
fundamental physics there's
there's a great degree of commonality
with some of the at least kind of
abstract questions
that come up in understanding the way
that things like chemical synthesis work
let's see
um
ah okay bunch of questions here boy you
guys ask about physics so much all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna
tackle another question it's very
different kind of question from pranjul
can aging be cured okay
it's a very relevant question for people
like me who are becoming very ancient
the um so the question is
one question is what is aging why do
organisms get old
and die of old age and all those kinds
of things
what what makes what what is the thing
that kind of
wears out in organisms that makes them
be old
we don't really know there are various
theories
but nobody really really knows which is
kind of shocking because it's one of the
sort of
most notable perhaps the single most
notable feature of the human condition
is that you know lifespans are finite
but we don't really know why that's true
now if we look at other organisms we'll
see
that there are uh there are situations
and there are organisms where for
practical purposes the lifespan is
infinite
where things don't seem to kind of where
you can keep replicating cells and keep
going keep going keep going it doesn't
really die out
actually one of the bad cases is that
that's exactly what tumor cells are
doing tumor cells
seem to be capable of just replicating
forever and sort of never getting old
but but coming back to kind of to to ask
the question of you know can we cure
aging first question is what is aging
what actually
happens what goes wrong that causes
organisms to kind of wear out there are
a number of different
features a number of different theories
maybe a number of different effects
so one very common one that's talked
about is uh
in dna replication um this is usually
called the hayflick limit
and the the what's observed is that um
uh after uh when you are going to have
mitotic division
standard cell division there are you can
only do that 50 times
before sort of something wears out and
you stop being able to go on replicating
so you know
the way we're all made there's sort of
one meiotic uh
division that is the um uh that's the
original sort of fertilized egg
um uh that where where we start you know
we start off from a single cell
and uh then we replicate replicate
replicate many many many
times each time the cells are splitting
in two so we're kind of doubling the
number of cells and
we don't we don't keep doubling forever
because we we differentiate into
different kinds of tissues
and it gets more complicated but um in a
first approximation
uh we're sort of growing by by by
um by doubling the cells by each cell
uh splitting into and getting two copies
of its genetic material
so each time that cell replication
happens the dna
inside the cell uh there is a second
copy of it made it and the two strands
unzip each other unzip from each other
and then the
the two individual unzipped strands will
get a second strand
formed that makes a full dna molecule
okay so the observation is that only
works 50 times
if you just keep doing that keep doing
that with dna it stops working
okay why does that happen it's kind of
known why that happens
these things called telomeres which are
the end caps on the dna
and what's happening is it's kind of a
counter
there's a particular i should know the
human telomere sequence but i don't it's
an
att a i forget it's not a very long
sequence
but there's a there's a particular
sequence of base pairs that is the human
telomere
and we have when that meiotic division
happens
roughly we get our initial cell
gets its dna has roughly 50
telomeres at the ends of the dna strands
and roughly what's happening is every
time there's one of these
one of these replication events um we're
losing one of those telomeres
and so gradually it gets to the point
where the dna
will just start uncoiling itself and
won't won't be properly
maintained if there's another cell
division and that's kind of
why microscopically there's a limit to
the number of cell divisions you can
make
okay now of course it's more complicated
than that as it always is in biology
so there's a an enzyme called telomerase
that adds telomeres
and so it's like well why do we lose
telomeres why why is that
um you know why is that causing things
to to um
uh to sort of unspool why don't we just
add telomerase and
and you know just you know put them back
in well it's more complicated because
that can lead to tumor formation you
know it's it's
it's all a complicated balancing act and
so on you know there are these
uh services where you can send your dna
and and they'll tell you how many
telomeres you have left
so uh so of course i did that because i
do all these kinds of things
and so it was like well you've got more
telomeres than you should have for your
age okay that's nice i
i feel young so that's good but i don't
necessarily believe that it's meaningful
and in fact
there's pretty good evidence that just
uh that you can actually
you know that you can increase the
number of telomeres by just
doing you know by eat well be healthy et
cetera et cetera et cetera
it's not clear that this sort of
inexorable story of every time the dna
replicates it loses a
telomere is right but anyway that's one
one source
of of um of sort of things that go wrong
with
age is if you replicate the cells enough
times
then um then they'll stop replicating
correctly the dna will sort of uh
will will fail there are other things
that happen for example every time you
replicate dna
there are some you know we've got six
billion base pairs in our dna
every time you replicate you get a small
rate of errors in the dna
well again that's more complicated
because there are proofreading enzymes
that come through and say oh i've
noticed there's a one bit error here
let me go and correct that at what point
do you get out of the range where
proofreading enzymes can work
well that's again part of the story of
tumor formation is that that that's
that's part of the mechanism is is when
things get sort of genetically out of
whack and proofreading enzymes can't
can't pull it back in again but in any
case that that's um
uh that's kind of another another
mechanism is the sort of progressive
uh you know errors building up in the
replication of dna
another mechanism the um uh
just general uh oxidative stress on
cells
just generally that um the the various
molecules and cells are um
uh get uh they get they kind of you know
they're oxidative they're kind of almost
burnt
by all these processes of metabolism and
so on it's just like
they don't work so well anymore because
they've got um things that were sort of
these very active pieces of molecules
no longer active because they're sort of
oxidated out
another kind of mechanism another
mechanism uh people often point to
our mitochondria as being uh something
that sort of wears out
over time you know every every cell in
humans
has uh it has what was probably
originally a parasite
uh it has these mitochondria in it which
are
uh separately replicating little pieces
of cells
uh have a pretty short genome sequence
that that
and they replicate separately when cells
replicate and and we all get them
uh it's all from uh from the female line
so you you have
uh your your mother's mitochondria um
and that
um uh that have just been sort of passed
down from cell to cells so to speak
and and then but mitochondria
uh they might have originally started as
parasites but they're really useful to
us
because they're kind of the energy
source for cells
and um uh there's sort of a a belief
that
um one of the things that may be going
wrong in aging is that there's
progressive degradation of micro
mitochondrial function
possibly due to oxidative damage
possibly due to other things
so those are a couple of different
different sort of ideas for
for what causes aging i mean one of the
one of the strange facts about aging
is that if you look at different
diseases for example you look at how
common these diseases are
they typically uh as a function of age
these diseases typically
increase in prevalence uh like roughly
like some kind of some kind of power law
you know it's it's the
the the square of the age the cube of
the age something like that
but if you look at the aggregate of all
things that kill one
the probability of of anything the
probability of death
increases exponentially with age that's
a that's a thing that's observed both in
humans
and in in for example complicated
machinery often has that same kind of
law
usually called gompert's law um it's
it's this
idea that the the the probability of of
of
of catastrophic failure or death in the
case of biological organisms
is is something that increases
exponentially with age
now by the way if you look at different
kinds of devices and how they fail
there's a very they have very different
distributions i mean some
some kinds of devices that their
probability of failure is more or less
constant with age
um some kinds of things like electric
light bulbs filament bulbs for example
are famous for this
they will go for a certain amount of
time and then kaboom at some particular
time they'll they'll they'll start to
fail um
and uh but this phenomenon of sort of
exponentially increasing failure with
time
not very well understood but something
that's observed in humans
as well as in as in various kinds of
complex uh
uh machinery something i've often
wondered
is what the analogy is between sort of
failure
and death in biological organisms and um
and what happens in computers because
you know you have your computer
you're running it it's running it's
operating system is running the computer
things happen to your computer you type
on your computer your computer gets uh
uh you know there's packets coming in on
the ethernet port there's
things happen to your computer um but it
keeps going it might run for months
you know the operating system is running
it's running it's running sometimes the
operating system now it gets more
sluggish something's going wrong
it's getting kind of old and tired and
then splat
it crashes operating system crashes
the thing effectively that session of
use of your computer just dies
the computer is restarted it's using the
same program for its operating system
comes back to life so to speak and then
keeps running for another few months or
whatever it is
and and that's that's sort of a little
bit similar to what we see in biological
organisms
in the sense that uh you know that
us us humans keep running for some
amount of time
and then uh you know one generation of
humans will die
and then the next generation of humans
are sort of being restarted
from well almost the same genetic
material then they're kind of running
for a while and
then they die and so on and i think that
that
uh is um that phenomenon of kind of
uh sort of you have this complicated
system where you've got
all these different things going on and
it's you know an operating system it's a
biological system
and somehow things go wrong over time
and eventually there's catastrophic
failure
that seems to be a generic kind of
phenomenon which we don't understand
very well
we don't understand it at all for
computers i mean with humans
we've been very you know we obviously
care about medicine
and so you know we have these diagnosis
codes you know the icd-9 icd-10
diagnosis codes where
where every different ailment has been
given a code so
these days i think icd-10 has like 100
000
different diagnosis codes you know a
uh you know this problem with this
this uh uh this organ this feature of
this thing etc each one of these has a
diagnosis code
and we kind of know uh in a little bit
of the sort of the
the structure of what the different
classes of diseases what the different
classes of things that can go wrong
with us humans are we don't really know
the same kind of thing for computers
nobody's really codified
sort of the diseases of computers in the
same way
that people have codified the diseases
of humans i mean
sometimes when a company is doing
technical support on its products like
our company
there's some degree of classification of
oh it's a problem
associated with this part of our
software system or something
but we don't really have you know the
icd codes for computers you know
diseases of the memory subsystem kind of
uh
you know trauma from device drivers
things like this
those don't really exist as as concepts
yet in the theory of of sort of the the
the life of computers um i think that
actually it would be pretty interesting
to study that we think it might tell us
something
about sort of the big picture of what
leads to
aging and decay in biological organisms
but so the question is what do you do
about it can you fix it
well you know we don't really know even
how to fix it for computers which is
in a sense a simpler problem you've got
an operating system running
and things are going wrong and what do
you do well
in the end you just say just reboot just
restart
it's like forget that generation just
let them all die restart new ones are
born
it's all good that's sort of the best
thing we know how to do
with computers that's a bit
disappointing be really nice if we could
say well we've got this operating system
running it's got all these problems it's
got
you know these pieces of memory that are
being you know filled up these buffers
that are all
you know messed up in this way in that
way and there's all kinds of little
problems
let's go send this this uh this fixer in
to go go fix the operating system go go
crawl through its memory figure out what
went wrong
fix this piece fix that piece and say
okay operating system you can keep
running for another year
so you know that's kind of what we'd
have to do on computers we to do the
same kind of thing for humans
well uh yeah we got to solve those kinds
of problems how might we solve those
problems
so a couple of different approaches i
mean first thing is
to know what's wrong i mean i think the
thing that probably
has helped medicine uh more than perhaps
anything else is just
being able to test things better being
able to know uh you know have better
kind of
prevention better knowing oh there's
something that's starting to go wrong
oh we can pull it back and fix it in
this way rather than
waiting for it to catastrophically fail
and then seeing what happens i mean i'm
afraid one of the things that i always
notice in medicine
is that one of the one of the general
facts about medicine is
something it seems to be going wrong
well it'll either get better or it'll
get worse
if it gets better usually it's like oh
be happy
we don't know what was wrong don't worry
about it if it gets worse
that's in a sense you know it's bad that
it gets worse
but in a sense that's good in terms of
diagnosing it because
when it gets worse it usually becomes
clearer what's actually wrong
sometimes when it isn't when nothing
particularly
when it's just a minor thing it's like
well there are 10 different things this
could be but when it gets worse
it's more obvious what it is and and so
i think one of the things that as we as
we go forward with
with um was sort of the curing aging
type thing one thing is know what's
wrong and know as soon as possible
what's wrong
and you know today you know you go you
can get uh
sort of off the shelf maybe a couple
hundred kinds of blood tests and things
done
you know in time and there are certainly
research projects along these lines
you can start measuring gazillions of
things in your blood you can look for
you know just that that little cell that
broke off from a little tumor that's
starting up
that little thing that's happening in
this place or that place and you can
start to detect those things
and if you know that something is just
starting to happen
it's much easier to pull it back than
when something has sort of
catastrophically failed
and so so i think one thing is just you
know the increased surveillance
of uh of just what's going on you know
in in
and i think one thing you'll realize is
if you do that
you will discover that everybody has
stuff going wrong in them
and the only question is does it get
worse or does it get better
and it it and i think then
you know it becomes the sort of more
dynamic process of maintaining
health for something by saying oh
there's this little thing that's you
know has this effect oh maybe you should
eat more broccoli or something
and that will be better or you should
eat more of things that have lots of
magnesium in them or something
and it'll get better or oh you should
take magnesium tablets or something
and it'll get better and but if you let
it go for a long time
oh i know in the case of magnesium maybe
you have some strange muscle
weakness issue or some such other thing
i'm i'm um
you know if you if you let that go for a
long time or something else go for a
long time
something else will get bad once
something has gotten bad
there tends to be this cascade that's
produced of one thing gets bad that
causes another thing to get bad another
thing to get bad
and so on that's one thing i think then
the thing that one can one can look for
is okay what about you know we've got
our immune system that goes around and
patrols and looks for bad things like
cells infected by viruses or or looks
for various kinds of sort of
intruders to the system and uh so one
question is can we do better than our
immune system
because we make an artificial immune
system with with our own
uh that that can sort of go around our
bodies and look for bad things that are
happening maybe look for
you know tumor cells that are developing
maybe look for something else
and uh maybe maybe do uh sort of a
careful
examination of this or that organ that
we couldn't really do from imaging but
we can certainly do it a molecular scale
and then kind of report back and say oh
there's this problem that's happening
or can we actually get those
uh you know pieces of
molecules to go and stand in for things
that were otherwise going on i mean
let's say you're making i don't know a
pancreatic beta cell that makes insulin
um you know could you make an artificial
such cell
that will respond in the same way to
let's say glucose levels
and produce insulin but it isn't a cell
that was made from
an actual you know that was actually
produced by us biologically
it was something that was introduced but
it's sort of an artificial cell
that's doing those kinds of things so
those are those are sort of
and it comes back to this kind of
molecular scale manufacturing one of the
best applications of molecular scale
manufacturing
is kind of interfacing to the molecular
system that is us so to speak
and being able to insert these kinds of
things now on a larger scale
there's also questions of you know what
organs can we replace
with um uh artificially what what organs
can we make a better version that has
been engineered
you know can we make you know successful
artificial hearts
lungs kidneys whatever else you know how
how well
how far can we go with that nature was
under a lot of constraints
when it created the biological system
that we have today
can we in a sense by doing uh
engineering
our kind of engineering can we do at
least as well or better
it's a tricky thing because interfacing
between the thing that's been
made by nature with all the pieces
fitting together and this thing that we
introduced with engineering
that's a tricky thing but but that's
another direction that that seems to be
being
successfully gone in now i mean
you know what will be will it be the
case that at some moment
you know in in in literature there's
often this idea of you know somebody
will invent the elixir of eternal youth
or a mythology i should say more
accurately and you know you just drink
it
and then you know you're young again and
you'll
you know you'll go on living forever
type thing um you know will that happen
or will it instead be something that is
more like um
that you know you you know oh this has
gone wrong let's go fix that more like
you know a house
for example where you know the house
it's not like
you pour an elixir over the house to get
it
to not you know require maintenance it's
like you know
a slate falls off the roof a uh you know
a thing
a i don't know this drain pipe you know
fails uh this piece of electrical
cable fails you know you gradually
replace those things
and it's kind of like you're keeping the
thing going for you know in the case of
houses hundreds and hundreds of years
um but you're doing that by by
incrementally fixing things
rather than by saying there's this magic
thing that is a sort of self-fixing
mechanism
but we don't completely know and and we
don't know enough
about aging to really be able to
distinguish those possibilities
i think one thing that has happened is
back i don't know 30 40 years ago
um you know i sort of paid attention
because i've been curious about the
phenomenon of aging for forever
and um 30 or 40 years ago people were
saying oh no you
aging is unstudyable there's nothing to
study there's nothing that we could
figure out about it there's no way that
we can change it
it's just an inexorable thing and that's
the way it is that's really changed and
there's a lot of study that's being done
about about this and about some uh you
know
there are a lot of different ideas about
you know removing senescent cells that
have died off being able to prune
the cells that one has so that one is
keeping only the vigorous young cells
they're all kinds of weird weird things
like which i'm afraid to have a certain
certain kind of um i don't know a
dracula feel to them of of
the the young blood idea if you take um
uh blood from younger people it seems to
have something in it
that um uh that uh is is good for
um uh for for improving health
that that one seems it has it has such a
character of of uh
of sort of vampirism or something to it
that i i
i find it hard to hard to believe but
you know one of the things that's often
funny about about what happens in
science
is these things that at first seemed to
be oh somebody wrote a story about that
100 years ago
you know that couldn't possibly be real
turns out actually
there's some twist on it that actually
is real and you sometimes almost resist
it
because oh my gosh it couldn't be like
the story that was written
but anyway i think that the um um you
know if we look at
kind of the the dynamics of um
of aging and so on you know my guess is
that there will be sort of
gradual improvement i mean we can see
you know in the us
for example if you look at the life
expectancy of people
it's been increasing at the rate of
about one third of a year per year
for the last 50 or 60 years that's
pretty good
that means that you know a uh one-third
of a year per year
means you know it's as as the years go
by people live longer
now of course if you could get it to
increase by more than one year per year
then you hit immortality if if the life
expectancy
is um if every year that goes by you get
more than one more year of life
expectancy then
then you conclude you know you can live
forever type thing
and and how that will work and you know
my guess is that
in a sense if we look at sort of human
history the
the probably the biggest discontinuity
will be
when there is effective immortality and
that may
arise from biological you know in a
biological way or it may arise in some
digital way where it's like oh well
you know okay uh you know the biological
stuff doesn't work forever but
you know all those things you're
thinking about you can capture
that in some digital way and you can
keep thinking about these things forever
type thing
um but not in a in a sort of biological
substrate
and um you know the question of what
what that means for the human condition
what that means for human society
when one reaches the point where there
is this kind of when there's no longer a
kind of
limit uh limited human lifespan it's an
interesting question and it's certainly
one where
where one wonders is it good is it bad
you know i think people have often
said that that um in the progress in in
progress
in society one of the things that can
sometimes
go wrong is if people
and i now rate myself in this collection
of you know
when people get you know people do
things over the course of their lives
and sometimes people do you know they'll
they'll just keep doing the same thing
the longer they live the longer the same
thing will keep on being done
maybe that's a good thing maybe that's a
bad thing depends on what it is and
depends on your view of it
but one of the things that that one can
notice is
if one wants a lot of change to happen
it's um
you know having having everybody having
a large fraction of people
you know be around for a really long
time and some fraction of them not
change is not a great formula for having
change happen
it doesn't always a great formula where
if you have you know if if it's always
a new group of young people either
because that has that you know there's
this sort of cultural change that has to
happen and that's not necessarily
achieved
by that either but but and change is not
necessarily intrinsically good either
but um that's something which you know
if we look at sort of the the long
arc of human history that's sort of the
question of whether we can expect
that for example if there is human
immortality what will that
what effect will that have on the future
of history what effect will that have on
on the degree to which things change in
the world or don't
um what effect will that have even as
even as we think about you know
individual sort of what people do it's
like
well you know i've been doing science
and
computation and technology and things
now for i don't know 45 years
and um it's like well if i'd been doing
the same thing for 500 years
what what would that be like um and
uh you know how does one think about
that kind of thing and how does one
think about the time scales you know
us humans maybe it takes 10 years before
you're pretty good at doing something
if you keep doing it and maybe if you
have a career that spans 40 50 years
that's you know that's a certain ratio
if your career spans 500 years
and it takes you just 10 years to get
good at doing something how does that
really work out what what is that
you know what does that what does that
sort of scaling look like
but um you know i i think these are uh
but but back to the original question
about sort of
curing aging you know it's a we don't
really know what's causing aging
there are sort of gradual things that
people start to understand about how to
improve this or that aspect
of the degradation that happens with age
but it's still a very piecemeal thing
and i don't know how that's going to
play out
although i certainly pay attention as i
get more and more ancient
let's see
okay there are various comments here
about about aging isn't death the
fundamental factor of evolution to more
sophisticated things
that was kind of what i was alluding to
i mean if you if
you know if all organisms were immortal
natural selection doesn't get to operate
the operation of natural selection on on
uh you know in modern technological
societies kind of complicated in its own
right though
and i think that the um in a sense
natural selection and its relationship
to intelligence
technology and so on is a bit
complicated i mean for example
if you are an organism that can't learn
then whatever your gut whatever you get
genetically that's what you have
if you have something genetically that
makes you unfit and kind of
dopey and you're not you're going to get
eaten quickly then you're going to get
eaten quickly
on the other hand if you're an organism
that can learn
even if you were born with some goofy
reflex that says jump into the jaws of
the shark or something
then you can learn to not jump into the
jaws of the shark
and um it it so and that's sort of the
the one level of sort of
being able to to to squiggle around kind
of
the the um genetic uh inevitability of
natural selection
as we start to be able to build
civilization and technology and so on
we get more ability to sort of move away
from
the kind of the raw struggle for life so
to speak that that's described by
natural selection
and quite exactly how that will end and
how that really works
is not not i it's not really well
understood at this point
um there's a question here from brian
about immortal jellyfish
yeah i mean there are there are all
kinds of organisms that that basically
you know where uh particularly when
there's asexual reproduction
and there's an organism and it just
makes more cells and makes more cells
and then it buds off another copy of
itself
and so on like a hydra or something like
that does this and
and what in what sense that is
immortality
is unclear i mean you know is that a
reasonable definition of immortality
i mean the sad thing is that the one
feature
one thing that gets to be immortal
that's around us humans is tumors
because almost the definition of of
something which is
which is uh you know a um a tumor is
that it doesn't stop
growing it just keeps on growing keeps
on replicating itself
it doesn't respect this hayflick limit
it just keeps going
and that's that's a you know it's a
feature of sort of the
evolved biological organism that it
knows when to stop
i mean there are the early organisms
probably didn't know when to stop they
just the stromatolites or whatever they
were in the pre-cambrian or
whatever they probably just kept growing
they just grow grow grow grow they
didn't
they didn't know when to stop and there
are some things like you know trees have
this
feature to some extent but some trees do
and some
some lower organisms molosts things like
that sometimes have this feature
that they just the older even fish
sometimes have this the older they are
the bigger they are
um and us humans we're more
sophisticated you know we grow only
until we're you know depends on i don't
know 15 20 years old something like that
and then we stop and at least we stop
growing up
um and uh we generally you know we
there's a limit
to growth and that that feature is
uh important to the way that we operate
as biological organisms
um and that feature might have something
to do with
uh the kind of the the um the the age
the aging issue i mean so one of the
things that i should have said is
is is aging a consequence of natural
selection
that is in the struggle for life
over the over the couple of billion
years that that life's been around on
earth
is it the case that uh aging and finite
lifespans turned out to just be a good
idea
that was sort of burnt in by biological
evolution
in a sense that the um the thing that to
us seems like a big bug
was actually a feature to evolution that
is
that um that it was the case that
evolution noticed
that if you have organisms that are
immortal and stick around forever
nothing changes
and uh sort of the badness just gets
badder
and um uh and it's and you don't get
you know good stuff coming in so maybe
that was a discovery
maybe death was a discovery of
biological evolution
and we are the uh the the you know we're
we're
the the bug for us was a feature
that it created and so what that might
mean
is gosh maybe there's something you can
just tweak
in the way that we're made genetically
or something that says okay switch off
the death
feature and um and you know then we'll
just keep living forever now the truth
is the way biology tends to work
is given that death was invented and it
was probably invented i i don't know the
not sure i mean certainly the early
organisms um even from
the the you know cambrian cambrian
period i'm pretty sure
we know that those organisms had had um
uh that they weren't just grow forever
type organisms
so i think that the the question of
of what um uh you know is it the case so
what probably has happened is
for at least a billion years biology has
been living with death so to speak
and so what tends to happen is once
biology locks onto some idea
it builds all sorts of crud on top of
that idea it builds all sorts of other
features on top of that feature
it's very much like what happens in
technology in the organization of
countries even
you know once there's a thing that's in
place a feature that's in place
all kinds of other stuff gets built on
top of it and then
that means that that feature is no
longer as flexible
you can't change that underlying feature
because there's this giant tower of
other things
that depend on the fact that oh you know
we've got this structure where
people graduate from high school at a
definite time okay that means we can
lock in these other things to being
resulting from graduating from high
school and there's a whole chain of
things
you say well actually we're not going to
do that anymore we're going to have this
sort of rolling thing where people have
no
particular moment when they're
graduating from high school or something
you realize oh my gosh
we built all these things in society
that depend on having this one
you know moment we can't change that and
so it may be with biology
that even though at one point death was
just a random feature that was added
that that by now we built so much stuff
on top of it
that it's really hard to remove that
feature or what we would now i think
consider a bug
so um oh gosh vook comments is there
anything more terrifying than living
forever
i think it depends on what you uh what
your point of view is i mean i
i you know this is this becomes one of
these personal
kinds of things i mean you know i kind
of have fun in my life typically
and um so it's like more of the same
please
but i i think it's it's a it's a
difficult thing to think about because
a lot of the rhythm of life of people's
lives is based on this idea that they're
finite
and if you remove that constraint a lot
of things become different i mean a lot
of
oh well you know like i'm
uh well at least i always claim that i'm
a terrible procrastinator i always put
things off until the last minute
i'm not sure that's quite supported by
all evidence but
but anyway there's certainly things that
i do put off until the last minute
and um if you do procrastination and
you're gonna live forever
you can procrastinate forever and it's
like well i was going to do that
thing oh yeah i meant to do that that
was ten thousand years ago
um and uh you know oh i'll get around to
it sometime
so it becomes a little bit less there's
not so much sense of urgency so to speak
in the things one might do and i think
it's also you know it's also a
complicated thing because you you say
uh i mean you know it's it's a
it's a very as i say it's a big
discontinuity in kind of the human
condition
because it's it's something where so
much
of the way that society is set up is
based on the idea of finite life spans
et cetera et cetera et cetera
that um it's really a lot of things have
to get remade if one removes that idea
yeah there's a question here from jonas
uh
uh are there ethical problems with
eternal life and what kinds of issues
would there be about resources and are
our resources finite
you know i think the thing to realize is
that
uh you know by the time
the universe is big and there
are and i suppose we could imagine a
moment
where which i find very difficult to
imagine actually
where it's like we've we've spread kind
of virus-like throughout the whole
universe
and we we are the future of the universe
so to speak
and you know i don't know is that um uh
do we think that's good do we think
that's bad i don't know
it's um uh it's it's something i'm not
sure that there's a
a fundamental ethical principle that
tells one if that's good or bad
i think that you know the it's like many
things if we say
you know uh how do we make sure that we
don't do anything bad
how do we make sure that the things
we're doing aren't bad well one way to
make sure of it is just don't do
anything if we humans didn't exist
then we wouldn't be doing anything bad
but we wouldn't do doing anything
so it's kind of like then you're not
really you don't really have a
a base for thinking about things and
then the question is
you know if if you imagine sort of uh
you know let's imagine that there's sort
of uh
biological humans digital humans
whatever
can live forever and you've accumulated
trillions quadrillions
of maybe you know disembodied digital
souls so to speak and you've got
you know you've got a quadrillion human
souls
and um you know and they are operating
in this
kind of computational framework that um
uh it's like okay are there uh you know
is that um
you know are you using up the resources
of the universe in operating these
digital souls so to speak well maybe yes
but maybe
maybe the resources of the universe can
be thought of as essentially operating
digital souls anyway
in a sense that's that's what there
isn't really a fundamental difference
at least based on this things like the
principle of computational equivalence
and so on
there isn't really a fundamental
difference between the computations that
just go on in physics
and the computations that might be the
future representation of our digital
souls
the only there is the differences we
know and care about
those computations that represent our
digital souls whereas
it's not clear you know when we just see
some process going on in nature
it's like well that's what nature is
doing but we don't care about that
so i think it's a very difficult um i
mean untangling the ethics of kind of um
uh you know digital souls and their
and whether whether we should think
differently
about computations that happen in
a piece of silicon that encodes
the digital souls of a quadrillion
people
versus the computations that go on in a
piece of silicon that's in a rock
how should we think differently about
these computations do we feel
i think we do feel we tend to feel sort
of
you know intrinsically we feel if you
destroyed
that piece of silicon that contains a
quadrillion human souls
that's really bad if you destroy that
rock it's like ah whatever
there are other rocks out there um or
something
we feel much more about i think
you know it's our it's our natural
tendency to feel much more strongly
about
things that are a representation of
human consciousness
than about things which are just a
representation of the computations that
happen in nature but it's not clear
there's a bright line difference between
those two things
it's really a question of how we how how
we feel about them and that's sort of
the defining feature and i think that
the um
um yeah so i think i think it's a it's a
tough thing to untangle
and i think that the the question of how
sort of ethics flows
in a world of immortality or a world of
digital consciousness
these are very complicated issues and
and i think they are
they are deeply informed by this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that i was talking about
in so far as if you say oh if
if uh this is kind of the difference
between different world systems if you
say
can you set the world up so that nothing
bad will ever happen
okay to be able to guarantee to do that
you have to be able to foresee all the
different kinds of things that can
happen in the world
you have to be able to make use of some
kind of computational reducibility
to be able to sort of put this blanket
around the world
to say i know enough about what's going
to happen in the world
that i know that these changes i'm going
to make now
are never going to lead to anything bad
happening for example
but in reality there's computational
irreducibility so
you think oh i'm going to make these
changes now and that's going to
make sure everything's going to be okay
but you can't do that because
it's this irreducible process by which
you you're kind of working out what's
going to happen in the world
and so you can't you there's sort of an
infinite set of patches that you have to
put in
to deal with all those different
consequences that happen from what
you're doing
so it's it's a kind of a and you know as
we think about sort of the digital
version of
of um of the future so to speak um those
kinds of questions about sort of how do
you put in place the ultimate laws that
will go in everything well you can't
because you'll always have these sort of
unexpected consequences that you'll have
to patch
and so on and that's really a story of
computational irreducibility
all right maybe one or two more
questions and then i really should wrap
up here
but um
here's a question from jonas say will
there be nano machines that reprogram
cells
to prolong life or even make it go on
forever yeah i think that's the that's
the real question i'm not sure
that it's a reprogramming question i
mean there's a question of okay you've
got to sell it's not doing so well
let's go you know send our nano machine
in go make an analysis
what's wrong with the cell oh it's not
producing this protein enough
okay let's go send in this nano machine
that goes and makes that protein for
this cell you know in a sense now again
there's almost an ethical issue that
comes up it's like
what do you do are you going in and
you see a cell and you say that cell
isn't working the right way
you know you say i'm going to fix it i'm
going to make this human the most
perfect human they can be
is that what you want it's not clear in
other words
if you say this is the gold standard for
what a human should be like
i'm going to go fix all the cells in
this human so that this human is like
that gold standard
well that's a weird thing it's not clear
you know
it's like well what should the standard
be you know it's like over the course of
history
what counts as uh uh as you know
a um a good-looking human has gradually
changed you know what counts as
whatever has gradually changed and i
think you know if
you start saying well let's just go in
and and you know fix it
uh you know what we can think about
doing that at the level of genetics
of doing genetic engineering on humans
that's a different thing this is a more
extreme thing of sending the nano
machines
and go fix the human as the human exists
and um
you know then what do you do you know is
it the case that
oh you know this human is getting old
and is getting less
you know less jumpy you know oh the
perfect human is much jumpier and as
much more
you know can can tap their finger more
quickly or whatever else
let's fix this older human to do that
well that has a bunch of consequences
which may or may not ultimately be
desirable consequences and again
it's it's sort of the you you can
imagine by doing that by saying
you know let's fix everything to be
perfect you have
and everything ends up being the same
and that has its other
you know that has another set of
problems and that that's kind of the um
uh what one could argue that some
aspects of education
um are tending to do that of let's make
everything the same
well that may not be uh may not be good
for the individual it may also not be
good for society to do that
but that's uh you know that that's
something that um you know that's a
that's a tendency there
all right maybe one um ah
let's see
um a question here from david
i'm not sure if i can do this one but
but um is infinity a semi-theological
concept
is infinity beyond counting and
measuring and therefore not
fundamentally an empirical concept
boy you guys are giving me you guys are
giving me difficult questions here
um in what sense is infinity
a a concept that we can wrap our brains
around
well if we imagine
so so one thing we can do is we can say
just imagine there's a thing called
infinity
like in our wolfram language
computational language there's just a
symbol it's called infinity
and say well what is it well for example
i can tell you that
1 over infinity is 0.
i can immediately tell you that just
from knowing infinity is what it is
1 over infinity is 0. what is infinity
plus
infinity oh it's just infinity again so
there are rules
that we can given that we have this idea
of infinity
we can reason in terms of this idea of
infinity there's nothing wrong with that
we can just treat that
as a symbolic thing and reason in terms
of that
i mean it's just like many things that
we talk about in the world
we may not know how they work or what
they really are
but we can still reason in terms of them
i mean we may say
oh i don't know uh something about um
the uh something about some feature of
cosmology about the large-scale
structure of the universe
we can reason in terms of those features
even though
black holes good example we can you know
even though we may not know even though
we might have one in our backyard
we can still reason in terms of them
even though
even though we may not be able to say uh
in detail
things about their nature so i think
infinity is a little bit the same way we
can
we can invent this concept which has
certain properties and we can then
reason in terms of these
those properties and then it becomes a
thing that is part of our sort of domain
of discourse about things in the world
now in in the question is can we
uh can we ever uh this
infinity thing can we make one could we
actually make one
physical components you know but there
are many things
that we can talk about that we can't
make with physical components
i mean one that was a long time one in
theology was souls
you know people said you can't you know
what do you do you know how much does a
soul
weigh that was an early that was a
question people used to ask as a way to
kind of
sort of poke fun at the notion of souls
from the point of view of
physical science so to speak is how much
does a soul weigh
everything weighs something you know how
much does a soul weigh
well we now know that kind of the notion
of something like a soul
is more a story of computation it's more
a story of what are the computational
processes that are going on in a brain
that are something that is is
representing
um thought knowledge whatever but is not
the the sort of the abstract
representation of that
independent of the physical
instantiation of the brain
so it's something we can we can in a
sense reason about souls we can reason
about thoughts
in a way that where we don't have to
physically instantiate the thought
so i think that um it's the sort of the
same thing with infinity
can we physically instantiate infinity
in our universe
well if our universe as we as we think
and pretty strongly from our physics
project
that our universe is finite the answer
is no
we can't instantiate infinity in our
universe maybe there are 10 to the 400
components
in our universe great that's a very big
number but it's not infinity
but nevertheless we can that doesn't the
fact that we can't instantiate we can't
construct one
in our physical universe doesn't mean we
can't reason about it
now you know when we think about
infinity there there are many
fine gradations of infinity that we can
reason a lot about actually
um famously gorg cantor in the 1870s i
guess
um invented this whole notion of
transfinite numbers
so you know you say okay let's count
numbers one two three four five six
seven eight
etcetera etcetera etcetera let's say we
just keep going we count forever forever
we just keep
keep on going we just keep on counting
what's the number that's
after the number that we get to we just
keep on counting we can give it a name
we call it omega
lowercase omega okay let's go beyond
that number it's omega plus one
let's um uh let's let's um let's
keep going and so on let's say we take
that number we take it
squared we take that number to the power
of that number
we they take that number to the power of
that number to the power of that power
that number
that number number of times you know we
keep on going we keep on having this
procedure for taking
this this infinite thing and sort of
just
reasoning with it making it making the
sort of bigger version of that infinity
well there's a whole theory of
transfinite numbers um that
allows you to think about these
different levels of infinity
it's not just one infinity you can
actually in a very fine-grained way
reason about levels of infinity
it gets very complicated actually and it
gets very wound up
with the definition of what we mean by
mathematics and the question of
finiteness of proofs in mathematics and
so on it's a
it's a it's a it's a very elaborate area
um
but it's something where there is this
mechanism for
kind of even though we can't hold
infinity in our hands by constructing it
with physical components we can still
reason about it
in a perfectly in a perfectly uh
systematic way
so i think that's that's some um
the way i would think about that and the
fact that we can't sort of reach
infinity
with physical components to know that
requires that we know the the the theory
of physics
and we think we we have great progress
in that in the last six months or so
and we think we can say that you you
can't reach infinity on our universe
um but uh but that's something that is a
fact from physics it's not an abstract
thing
all right uh i think we should probably
wrap up here although these questions
are lots of fun
and um uh
yeah well gives us some uh
lots of good questions um um
to uh um
yeah lots of interesting questions here
all right things to look forward to for
next time
great well thanks for thanks for joining
us and
um look forward to seeing you again next
week i think i think we will do one of
these next week even though it's some
thanksgiving time in the us um i should
be uh
uh around and available and um
uh this is always fun so thanks for
joining us